Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
July 1st,
2013 oh my God.
Is it July already?
I feel like this summer's going by and I haven't even put on a strapless yet.
Oh,
have another fucking Kevin.
Another vodka and fucking something stupid drank.
All right.
Now why are all the wires tangled up to Christ?
And this is no way to start a podcast.
What's going on?
Jesus fucking Christ.
Isn't this amazing?
Just how fucking tangled up some shit can get.
You know,
how does snakes do it?
It's going around.
They're basically like a fucking Mike.
Why aren't they that could kill you,
some of them.
Sorry on and do this.
Fuck.
Is this any way to start a podcast?
Is it putting a wind screen back on it?
I have.
I use a wind screen inside.
All right,
so if you're new to my podcast,
that's the level of intelligence that you're going to be dealing with.
Do you think as a snake,
right?
If you're not poisonous,
that's gotta be like suck in it's sports,
you know,
for a human being.
And you go into gym class,
what exactly do you do if you're a non poisonous snake?
You mean you can't fucking grab anybody cause you ain't got no.
What do you do?
What does,
how does a gardener garter snake.
There's a gardener.
Oh Jesus.
How the fuck does a non poisonous snake eat?
Okay.
It just has to eat shit alive.
Just,
you know,
shit that isn't tougher than it and it's just got to lash out at it
is the fucking thing squirming around.
God.
What a life.
You know,
and I tell you,
you got to commend the Gartner or Gardner or Garner,
James Garner,
snake.
You really have to commend them for the,
um,
for their attitudes.
Like you meet them.
They're not,
they're not really bad people.
You know what I think I'm going to do?
I think I'm going to write a thank you letter.
Yeah.
And I'm going to put it in the fucking Gartner snake,
garter snake,
whatever the fuck it is,
newspaper.
And just thank them.
You know,
just try and shine a little light on the snake and then I'm going to sign it
myself.
Dude,
what's the,
I really have to fucking address this right out of the gate.
I used to like the Blackhawks organization.
I sat there through six fucking games watching that phenomenal team basically
kicked the Bruins ass.
I mean we,
I mean they beat us is six games,
nine know that weren't blowout games but still,
you know,
they just were better than us.
And here I am coming to the acceptance that we were two games short,
that we were two games to one up,
you know,
three games in.
All we got to do is split the next two.
And we went in and we fucking,
we didn't,
we never win another game.
Lost three games in a row.
That's fucking tough.
And then that ends NBA is over and now I have to somehow come out of the high
paced level of Nhl Hockey and excitement of the NBA finals too.
Like the dog days of summer baseball.
Hi,
an inside ball to daddy day for a ball game.
If you're a dao cub,
dow this Saturday,
this Saturday is a hat with a propeller on it day verse 40 douchebags that show
up.
Get one of these,
I don't know why you'd want,
but they're afraid.
So you know,
people are going to come anytime it's free.
Oh,
the fatty show up.
Um,
so I'm sitting here trying,
you know,
to all right.
But it's a great thing.
You know,
we're competitive,
we've got a great team,
we've got a great base,
so we can build on who knows,
maybe next year,
right?
So I'm starting the healing process of it.
And what are these do?
The Chicago Blackhawks,
they take out a full page ad in like the fucking Boston Globe.
And this is the best part.
Rather than just saying,
oh,
by the way,
in case you forgot,
we kicked your ass in the Stanley Cup finals,
these fucking cunts have the nerve to write a thank you letter to the Boston
Bruins organization.
And to all there,
this is the greatest thing ever.
Classy fans.
It was one of the biggest douchebag,
deuce chill inducing events in sports.
I since,
I dunno when,
since maybe Lebron James,
the decision,
can you fucking believe that?
First of all,
first of all,
let's just act like this was sincere and this was not grand standing by the
Chicago Blackhawks organization to just shine a light on them.
So everyone got to be like those guys.
Classy isn't that swell?
Because that's basically all that letter achieved.
Okay?
Okay.
I don't wanna speak for the entire Bruins fan base,
but we don't need a fucking pat on the head telling us we're classy.
But you fucking brought Eaton conch out there with your Freddie Mercury
mustaches.
The fuck do you think we need that for?
We played a seven game series.
It only went sick.
You were the better team.
Our team shook hands with your team.
What's it classy?
Faint.
Do you fucking believe the balls
on those fucking black cock cons?
Can you believe?
First
of all,
I want you to find an article out there,
cause I know all the Blackhawk fans will like,
it was a play.
She moved gay.
Gay was Shane.
Thanks to the Brood Day.
Didn't have to do that.
Let me ask you fat open heart surgery cuts out there.
Huh?
Every nine out of 10 people out in Chicago have that Zipper scar right up the
middle of their fat fucking torsos.
All right,
and I was nice to them.
The whole fucking playoffs.
Playoffs,
right?
Dude,
I want you to find one fucking article out there about the Blackhawks thanking
the Bruins that actually has the writer then talking about like,
wow,
what a great organization the Bruins are,
man,
they're fans are so classy.
The Blackhawks actually had to address it a week after the series was over.
What is it about the Bruins organization that makes them so classy?
Marv?
All I got to tell you,
ever since the days of heady shore,
I want you to find one of those articles because I'll tell you there's not one.
All that letter of apology did was facilitate more fucking praise for the
Blackhawks.
Like,
well you can,
you pull leaves.
These guys,
they wouldn't have
the Stanley Cup.
They just take,
they have the tussle.
A lot of flack,
that fucking horse shit just heaping more fucking praise on him.
It was actually,
it was a brilliant move by them.
You know what I mean?
You know what it looked like?
Like debt.
They'll look like they were drunk texting,
like Dave won the Stanley Cup and then they would have had so much booze.
They get to that point right before you pass out.
We just thinking of all the great people in your life and you want to start
crying.
So you start calling people up,
call your buddy up who doesn't have a drinking problem like two in the morning
and he's freaking out.
That is fucking something happened to his mom.
And how did she fall down again?
Picks up till now.
Really mark,
I didn't want to tell you.
You know,
look,
I'm drunk.
I don't jog based way.
Thank you.
You know what?
It's going to be my friend,
man.
That's what the fuck they did
to it.
That letter of apology is a fucking embarrassment to hockey.
And if this starts a trend
where every year I swear to God,
next year somebody's going to win and they're gonna be a,
well no.
Now we have to write a letter of thanks.
Can you fuck if they wrote a letter of thanks telling how classy broods fencer,
can you just take that in for a second?
I'm actually going to wait five minutes of silence to have to wait from Montreal
Canadien fans to stop fucking rolling on the ground laughing.
Okay,
you're back.
You're blue block.
Eight doses up there,
right.
I've been watching the Bruins since the early eighties I'm going on 30 years of
being a fan.
Never has anyone ever even remotely suggested that Bruins fans are classy.
We're a bunch of fucking animals now.
I left.
I left Massachusetts in 1995 okay.
So there was a disconnect to me with that city.
But do you remember last year when the Bruins got knocked out of the playoffs?
Playoffs.
We lost in overtime and that Dude Ward,
forget his first name,
scored for the Washington capitals and unfortunately
the dude was African American,
any beat the Bruins and literally like an eighth of our fan base went on Twitter
and started dropping the n word like it was 1938,
you know,
I don't know why I picked 1938,
you know what I mean?
It's somehow within a fucking year,
we are so God damn classy that the Chicago Blackhawks have to take time off from
drinking out of that cup.
That you know,
she fucking,
Ciara took a shit in it,
right?
I hope he did.
Um,
they had to take time out to see how classy we are now.
Either did Chicago,
Black Hawks are the biggest bunch of fucking morons ever,
which there's no way they are because they want it three years ago.
Completely dismantled their team and what we're able to build it back up again,
like the fucking mom,
right.
Or the Chicago Black Hawks and the city of Chicago is so fucking racist that
even that absolute public relations debacle of last fucking year,
that absolute embarrassment that made me feel shameful that I was from that
fucking city.
Okay.
It's so pale.
So in comparison to the unbelievable fucking level of racism in Chicago that day
didn't even notice it.
You know,
I bet this is how race is.
Chicago is,
I bet last year when they saw some Bruins fans reaction towards scoring that
goal that they,
they're so fucking racist that they,
that actually warmed their heart a little bit and they probably already penned
the first draft of that thank you fucking letter.
I don't know if you've ever been to Chicago,
but it is brutally fucking racist,
you know,
as his boss the,
but we somehow we get all the fucking attention about it.
Like the racism is in the south and it's in Boston,
you know,
like they don't go to Pittsburgh where the other side of the tracks is literally
the other side of railroad tracks.
Literally walk across railroad tracks and instantly you're the only white person
on that side of the tracks.
Um,
anyways,
that was,
you know,
I still like the Black Hawks,
but if you think I fell for that on any fucking level,
that letter of apology.
Do you remember earlier this year where Jeroma Gillnet had the choice of maybe
going to the Boston Bruins?
Oh maybe go into the Pittsburgh Penguins,
you know,
and it was a close decision and he decided to go to Pittsburgh.
Wouldn't you think that maybe that horrific reaction that Bruins,
some,
some Bruins fans to be fair had after losing last year?
Maybe tip the scale cause you got two great teams,
you know,
I know a lot of people,
well I guess Pittsburgh's fucking racist too,
but they never,
they never get,
they never get it.
They don't get any press on it.
You know,
all they talk about there is a hardworking steel town at,
there's no steel mills anymore.
And anybody who had balls and made steel and built the bridges is at least in
their eighties at this point.
So it's a bunch of button pushing computer conch downtown at this point.
But uh,
they still wear hard hats to the game.
Um,
I'm sorry.
People like that,
that,
that fucking look the end of the day,
all that letter of apology did was just heat more praise
on the Blackhawks.
It was the Ron Burgundy moment.
I look good.
I mean really good.
Oh God,
I love,
that's what they did.
So let me tell you something.
Chicago Blackhawks Organization and your entire fan base,
you can take your fucking,
thank you.
You're a whatever the fuck that was that letter you wrote from summer camp.
You can fuck and crumble it up.
Yeah.
How did,
how did the rock used to do that and shoved straight up your candy?
Yes.
Please don't ever do that again.
Other,
if any other organisations are listening to this,
please don't do that.
That,
that fucking just please don't do it.
It was such a great finals.
Two original six teams.
One of my favorite moments of the playoffs was when that whatever that,
that,
that content that I respect that passed on a Chicago was holding up.
He's holding up the fucking Stanley Cup and he's still bleeding from the series.
Even in boxing,
they stopped the fucking blood.
You know,
they got some guy that pressing down on it with that fucking that compress thing
and he's got his gloves and shit and it's just talky
guys fucking bleeding and like it doesn't even,
you know,
white owl I guess UFC,
UFC,
that could be bleeding pretty bad.
I'm just what?
Look,
you have to go to literally sports where they're beating the shit out of each
other.
Um,
and by the way too,
all you fucking non hockey fans who still think it's the slapshot error.
There was not one fight the entire series.
It was phenomenal for all you fucking pansies out there.
You know,
sitting in your Afghans while wearing aprons who wait for Olympic hockey and
then lie.
It's true hockey fans going,
you know,
if this is the way hockey was,
I would watch it now.
You wouldn't,
you wouldn't because that is the way it is.
You fucking idiot.
Those are all NHL players in the fucking game.
You asshole.
Oh,
I am on a tear this week.
So they,
you'd go,
fuck you,
Chicago.
Congratulations.
Congrats.
You know what I should do?
Hey,
why don't we have a donation thing here.
Everybody fucking,
uh,
donates money to the Monday morning podcast and I'm going to put,
I'm going to buy out some ad space in the Chicago Tribune and write a thank you
letter for the thank you letter so I can see somehow,
well,
what would a classy podcast,
I know he says cunt,
every other word I know he can't read out loud.
Well,
this is just a decorative on the blah,
Blah rock fucking losers.
Uh Oh,
deuce chills.
I got halfway through the letter and I had to stop reading.
Okay.
I just stopped.
It was like,
it was like,
it was like eating lemons and that there's no fucking way.
How do you not know how country you fucking move?
That is,
it's actually hilarious if that's how they meant it to just,
hey,
you know what?
I bet they're just starting to get over losing in the finals.
Let's fucking remind them.
You know what it's like?
It's like when you break up with some chick,
right?
And it's like the women have that sixth sense when they can tell you start to
have good days and you get in past them.
So they fucking call you up and just mind,
fuck you all over again.
All right,
I'm done.
I still can't hate the Blackhawks cause I fucking have always liked that team
and I've always loved that uniform.
But Jesus,
that is a fucking,
I don't know what to tell you.
They already traded Dave Bowling.
Can you believe that?
He's fucking guys getting draft picks.
You're going to trade a fucking guy.
You're going to trade a guy with ice water in his veins at the most crucial
moment in the season.
He's just such a fucking great player,
I think.
I think the maple leafs got a fucking steel and I think they learned something
with that,
that uh oh wait a minute now.
They've always been doing,
they got Phil Kessel and they gave us a bunch of draft picks,
but we drafted,
well,
all right,
just wait,
strike all of that.
But I think the,
I think the maple leafs got a lot better and the Blackhawks got a lot worse.
I am not a big fan of draft picks.
Like,
Hey,
let's take this proven Guy Dave Bolen.
He's one of those guy.
He's one of those guys.
Those are the guys that when you're the fucking cup,
you know everybody always looks at the stars and all its stills.
Fucking those fucking guys like him.
Okay?
You just come in and fucking knock,
you stick off the puck and all of a sudden he's got the puck right over to the
slot.
And then the big fucking shiny superstar scores.
Those fucking guys in the corner.
I'm telling you,
I wish the Bruins got him.
You know I'm going to write a letter of thank you to the Chicago Blackhawks for
getting rid of one of their best players.
Uh,
Blackhawks.
Thanks Bruins.
City of Boston in open letter.
Okay,
so basically this article,
this is an a Toronto,
they say the Chicago Blackhawks pen to full page open.
Thank you.
Letter to the Boston Bruins and the city of Boston Friday just four days after
being the Bruins to win the Stanley Cup.
It's signed by and all they have a guys.
So they basically quote the entire thank you.
And then the last paragraph,
it's gotta be about the Bruins.
Right?
It's gotta be because there so fucking classy right now.
It goes,
it was a classy way for the hawks to wrap up a season that culminated with their
second cup in four years.
Chicago won the best sear,
uh,
the best of seven series 42.
After gutting out a three to come back from behind winning game six,
Monday in Boston.
You see what I'm set?
That's how all of them were.
There was nothing about the Bruins and had all to do with Chicago.
You fucking did it.
That was like a chick move I got to give you.
That was definitely,
ah,
that makes it even worse.
We lost to a bunch of brides.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Dude,
that was right up there.
That,
thank you.
I'm gonna just keep going on this thing.
That fucking thank you letter was right up there with Sally field going,
you like me?
You really liked me.
You know those moments where you're like,
Oh God,
you know
that big drunk woman who married the fucking old guy?
Do you have like I buy the
Oh,
getting uncomfortable.
Just thinking about her
gross fucking Gross Chicago that that letter was fucking gross.
And if,
if this was the attention to make me feel this way,
then hats off to you are by your fucking around a drinks,
the whole fucking city.
I'll buy your fucking round of drinks if this is what you wanted to achieve,
that that letter was worse than losing the fucking series.
That's how bad it was.
Ah.
All right.
Did I get it all out of me?
I don't know.
Okay.
I Dunno.
Um,
what a fuck did we go from here?
Let's just just,
just dive right into it.
So I've been keeping up on the Snowden thing,
trying to see where this guy's going to land.
I'm rooting for,
I don't know about you guys
and I'm sick of people talking about him like he's a fucking rat.
I think the guy,
I think he's a hero.
You know,
this should be more whistle blowers.
This is just an unbelievable fucking amount of power to give anybody.
They've got a great article,
the whole who's watching the watchers,
you know what I mean?
Dude,
this is like what this guy was working on that I've basically glanced over and
articles because once I get intimidated by high long shit is I have to stop
reading.
Um,
what this guy is fucking working on.
You have to understand that like that's game set and match.
They don't even have to whack people anymore.
They don't,
if they just have every fucking thing you ever did and ever said on the phone,
text,
it's fucking over.
Okay.
Fucking over.
Don't look at me.
What,
what office could I run for?
Let's just say I didn't do a podcast,
but you guys know my sense of humor.
All right?
How arrogant was that?
Uh,
you guys know me.
I'm a fucking loose cannon,
but a douchebag.
Um,
anyways,
I'm rooting for this fucker guy right now.
He's looking to land,
I believe in Ecuador,
which is really hard when even everybody down to my level knows where the fuck
he's trying to go.
I think this kid's heart was in the right place and I think he saw what he was
building.
He saw it for what it was.
As much as it could stop terrorism,
it also gave a bunch of fucking potential sociopaths and ability to build up or
absolutely fucking destroy anybody that they wanted to.
And um,
you know,
that's just a,
uh,
it's too much power.
If you,
if you look around the world,
the amount of places right now where people are protesting because they are
absolutely sick of the people in power and how they're running things,
you know,
can you imagine being in that situation?
Like
just having a fucking dictator and the guys get know kidnapping and raping and
just gassing your own fucking,
people just can imagine being in that fucking situation.
Like that's,
you know,
when your life starts,
that's what's going on in your country and you've got to spend your whole
fucking life trying to topple that.
And now you're going to have something in place like this where,
I mean everybody's got to try to like start an entire revolution by talking,
you know,
sitting there with their hands over their mouth,
like Joe Pesci and Deniro and casino.
You know,
I think that Arab,
they saw it for what it was,
is like Jesus Christ,
he's fucking guys.
These guys look out.
Look at what can happen with these social networks.
Now
I saw a thing over and uh,
Bahrain or something,
these people go to prison for criticizing the king.
First of all,
you shouldn't have a fucking king this day and age.
You know,
a king.
How fucking older you grow up,
get a fucking job,
right?
So people tweet a,
I think the king's a bit of a con and they go to jail for a year.
And I might be paranoid,
but I think this is the road we're going down.
You know?
Ah,
Jesus,
Bill,
you're in way over your head.
I know I am,
but it's fun.
That's what this section is every,
every fucking week.
Now when I,
when I,
uh,
do world,
when I do world politics,
not discuss him,
not read about them when I do them,
no,
seriously,
I'm rooting for that guy.
You know,
and I'm a paranoid fucking psychopaths,
so take it for what it is.
But uh,
you know,
I see all the average Douche bag.
You just,
he goes from nobody to be in a bouncer at a club.
Nine out of 10 people,
human beings can't even handle that level of power and they become a dick.
You know,
the next thing you know,
they're trying to finagle fucking blow jobs out of girls dressed like whores for
whatever particular reason,
just so they can get in this club and go in there and damage their hearing and
possibly get herpes right.
Isn't that the club scene,
man?
All right.
Two advertisers this week,
everybody settle it to advertisers that are going to change your life and how
you feel about it.
Eva [inaudible] everyone.
All right,
look,
having your own receptionist would be great.
Hell,
it even be phenomenal.
But paying their salary is really expensive.
That's why hundreds of thousand of this goes into sweatshop labor.
I'm quitting this podcast.
MMM.
That's why hundreds of thousands of entrepreneurs are now using eve ways to
enhance their image,
work faster and make more money.
Oh,
good.
It had a happy ending.
Here we go.
You can try.
He voice right now for free.
When you go to the podcast page on bill bird.com and click on the banner with an
e voice account as your virtual assistant.
You can get your,
uh,
your own local or toll free number and dial by name directory.
All your calls will be professionally answered and routed wherever you want.
Eve always starts at just 10 bucks a month,
10 bucks a month eve voice even transcribes your voicemail messages and emails,
emails,
emails them to you instantly,
just like what the real receptionist.
But without the high cost.
You can operate like a top executive,
but stay lean like a startup and blow away your competition.
He voices even mentioned as a key tool for today's businesses and both ink and
Forbes.
All right,
I made you do this everybody.
I believe any voice and I want you to try it for free right now for 30 days for
your free trial of ee voice,
go to [inaudible] dot com Promo Code Bill.
That's he voice.com Promo Code Bill,
or just go to the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com and click the voice banner
right now.
All right,
please do that.
Can you please do that for me?
Uh,
and when you're done doing that,
um,
you're probably thinking like,
you know,
I really enjoy watching TV.
I wish there was a more efficient way to do it.
Well,
obviously red face has the way Hulu plus every one you've tried screaming hit
shows on your PC,
on hulu.com.
Now it's time to start your free trial of exclusive content in your living room
and on your mobile devices,
on Hulu plus with Hulu plus,
you get total control to watch thousands of shows wherever you want,
whatever you want.
Use Hulu plus on connected TVS,
game souls,
blueray players,
Roku,
apple TV,
PC,
or watch from anywhere on your smart phone or tablet on demand at all times.
And with Hulu plus you can binge on full seasons.
What's your favorite current shows?
And even full series runs of classic TV shows.
It's endless.
They got community,
modern family,
south plaque,
SNL,
Jimmy Kimmel,
family guy,
and more who the plus is only seven 99 per month,
but right now they're offering an extended free trial of Hulu plus that is only
available to my podcast.
Listeners,
take control of your TV watching experience.
How do you do it?
You go to the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com you click on the Hulu plus
banner for your extended free trial or go to the Hulu plus.com/bill again,
click the Hulu plus banner on the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com or just
simply go to Hulu plus.com/bill a righty.
That's the advertiser for loosely cause every bloody.
Um,
where did we go from
here?
Oh Man,
I hate a fucking had a bad day yesterday.
I had been trying to drop weight.
You know,
I got all the way up to a buck 85.
So now back into the one seventies,
cause that's how I do it.
You know,
I don't know about you guys,
but I,
there's no goal in my life that includes me wanting to be a fucking lard ass.
I just don't want to do it,
you know,
be that guide,
bending over to tie his shoes,
like
fucking head turning all red.
You know,
I don't want to do that.
I want to be that guy rolling over on my woman.
Right?
She can't even breathe does,
she's got to get on top of me.
I still want to fucking do that,
you know,
pushing my gut up towards my face and she could find my dick.
I don't want to be that guy.
This is like a testimonial.
So I've been eating pretty much as good as I can as far as bike,
uh,
knowing what's bad for me and sort of knowing something more about what's good
about,
about food for me,
good about food,
you know,
try and eat the right foods.
Just,
just,
just bear with me people.
All right.
I'm not a smart man.
Okay.
Half.
The reason why I do this podcast gives a fuck.
I do this podcast to promote me and all my standup gigs.
But one of the,
in an unintentional upsides to this podcast is it really has to make you feel
better about yourself.
Certainly your re your reading out loud skills.
Did you hear the particular moment where I started mind fucking myself during
the voice read?
But did you notice how I went Dave Bolen and I fucking collected myself and then
I delivered during Hulu plus.
Did you notice that?
Um,
anyway,
so tell him I talking about,
so I've been trying to work out here.
They'd going on hikes and each day I go on a little bit longer of a hike and a,
these are the real hot months and I wasn't even thinking and I brought my dog
out and went on this long hike and you know,
I brought her water and all that type of stuff.
But I didn't know a dog could get a sunburn.
I know,
I know.
I've,
I just made a great podcast.
Now you're all going,
whoa,
she's fine.
But the top of her nose,
she has little flakes on it.
I feel fucking horrible.
Horrible.
And then I think she was walking on the dirt for too long and it was hot.
Like she was walking real gingerly last night.
So she had a flaky knows and she had a little tender pause.
Do you know what it's like to see a jacked pit bulk or
is it's walking down the fucking street and not complaining.
Still wagging its tail.
I feel fucking horrible.
So this morning I literally carry my dog like a baby out to the grass and I let
it do its thing and I carry it fucking back.
And one of my neighbors like,
oh,
what happened your dog?
And I'm like,
Oh,
you know,
feed her.
I couldn't be like,
I'm a terrible person.
That's what happened.
Okay.
Cause my own vanity,
you know,
cause I don't want to have a head the size of a mini keg.
I took my dog on too long of a fucking walk.
You know,
I'll tell you what's great about a fucking dog is if right now,
if I asked her if she wanted to go for a walk,
like her head would pop up,
she'd absolutely freak out and she toughed it out again because that's the level
of loyalty that a dog has.
The kind of loyalty
that a cat would never happen.
You know that Jesus will you,
you're going to do dog and cat material.
What is it?
The eighties.
Why don't you go upstairs and go put on a blazer?
Pull up you fucking sleeves to the elbow.
Ah,
get some hair extensions.
Seek can actually grow a fucking mullet
and compare the two.
Um,
yes,
I feel fucking horrible,
but I haven't losing weight.
Everybody.
My goal,
I want to get down to about a buck 68 but I want to be fucking shredded.
Just one more time.
I want to do it all.
Do it.
Tell me
what,
give me fuck head as being far.
I go completely ball.
Oh,
I won't chicks to look at me and like my Frat goop stomach.
Just one more fucking,
Ooh.
Haven't had abs since early nineties.
Sorry.
Um,
you know,
sometimes when I'm in a fucking silly mood I like to come out on stage.
So that stuff to captain,
it's a kneel like the second show on a Saturday night.
Do that to me one more time.
It just puts everybody in a silly,
goofy boot.
I start dancing around like an idiot.
Girls put their head on somebody's shoulder,
you know,
girls do that shit when they just see somebody and joy in life and they just go,
hey,
what do you enjoy life too?
They just put their head on their shoulder.
All right.
Um,
Joe Head on my show.
Why your make up off on my shirt
Bu du,
Du,
Du.
It will never come out.
You Selfish Lady Lady.
Um,
all right,
let's get to some sort of um,
oh,
this is kind of weird.
You know,
cause I'm trying to learn the uh,
all the capitals.
I can go from fucking uh,
Rick Avik Iceland,
however the fuck you pronounce it,
all the way over to the Philippines at this point.
It's great.
Now I kind of like know where they are.
I always get like,
uh,
Asia was a Middle East was rough
and you'd think about how many times we've gone over there and we bomb shit that
I would kind of touch,
start to look at the other fucking yeah.
The other countries around there.
But you just don't,
you know,
you know what it is,
is wherever you live.
That's what,
you know,
GI bill.
That was really deep.
You got any more fucking literally,
literally,
hopefully enough.
I'm such a fucking moron.
Why do you listen to this?
Huh?
Um,
no.
You know,
wherever you are,
you just sit there and you watch the weather and they'll have least in the
United States of America.
I met Rick,
um,
White America.
What the fuck?
Who did that one?
That's one of those songs I listened to like two seconds of it.
Oh,
by the way,
is there a white Al Sharpton out there that I can call for being offended?
I watched that devious maids last night because I was just,
I just got to see how they're going to get five years out of that.
Absolutely horrific fucking premise.
And if you can just see how they make the fucking,
the,
the white characters on that show.
I swear to God it's the fuck you got to watch it.
All right.
Devious maids.
Put that on your watch list.
You have to watch the white characters on that show.
It's fucking hilarious.
They make them so cartoonishly evil like order the maids,
all the maids are Latino.
The whole fucking show really if you look at stereotypes is probably pretty
fucking annoying.
Um,
so all the maids a Latino,
right?
They work in for these fucking rich white people.
I think they had one Latino couple just to fucking level it off just beyond evil
white people.
So this is one of them is like a movie star and she needs to get a facial and
her Latino made is for Casey Latino.
One more time.
Her fucking made is crying.
Okay.
Cause she's trying to get her kid up from like Honduras or wherever the fuck
they're from,
but they're dead.
Dad died.
It's basically good times set in Central America,
you know.
Damn Damn.
Damn.
However you say damn it.
Spanish
both nods.
Bitch.
I don't know what the fuck you anyways,
so she's sitting there crying cause she wants to get a kid up there and,
and the,
and the fucking little white lady is listening and use your seeing emotions on
her face.
You Think,
oh finally they're going to actually show that a white person can have a heart
on this show.
And then the person she just goes like,
yeah,
so where's the father is the abutted and she's just like,
oh
okay well I can't give you time off to reach out to your kid cause I have to get
a facial.
Oh it's a fucking phenomenal shelf.
Meow everybody.
Me fucking Yo.
And I know that there's a bunch of morons watching the show,
you know from the Latin community.
Go and see.
That's how white people are.
They don't take care of their kids.
They're all rich and they're all getting fate.
Not saying every Latino person,
but I know a good certain percentage.
You know what?
I get white people deserve it though.
Cause we've been doing that forever.
Right.
It's about time to stereotypes.
And the ignorance came back around to our neck of the woods.
You know what?
Good on you.
Horny housemaids of the fucking Osi,
whatever the fuck it's called.
Devious housemates.
They're devious.
Everybody.
Yeah.
You,
you fucking pay attention when they do that turndown service.
You don't know what they're liable to do those devious maids.
Um,
anyway,
so let's go also.
Anyways,
I've,
I've been trying to keep up on,
uh,
you know,
learning the capitols and no one where shit is like all these years to listen to
fucking Bob Seger singing about cat.
Man Do.
I didn't even know where it was.
So Naipaul everybody.
Do you remember Bob Seger?
Speaking of fucking Kevin,
that roast beef torso,
you know the buttons Burston on his fucking Western shirt,
swam and the cat man,
I used to sing that in the warehouse that the way I ran it down to,
hey man.
Hey,
get outta here.
I'll go on a cat,
man.
And I,
I always thought I'd,
okay,
you're a good dude.
He's code.
I always thought it was in like Mexico.
It's in Naipaul.
I've thought Naipaul was the capital of fucking India.
It isn't Naipaul's a fucking country.
New Delhi is everybody New Delhi.
I always thought,
you know,
it'd be,
that'd be a great idea for a fucking sandwich place.
You get a bunch of guys from India,
from New Delhi come over here.
They started deli,
they make American sandwich is better than Americans and they call it New Delhi.
You get it,
it's a new Dell.
But after a year it'd be like,
Whoa,
this is still the new day.
Um,
anyways,
so I was looking up some shit and somehow,
okay,
I'm getting so into the geography.
I'm starting to look up like islands in Guam.
And I remember,
I,
you know,
a few weeks ago when I was talking about the Spanish American war that I thought
took place in like fucking Texas,
you know,
and involve the Alamo.
And then I discovered that it was fought over in the Philippines and I believe
Guam,
I can't even remember in Puerto Rico,
something fucking nuts like that.
Something had a fucking remember.
Um,
so I started looking up on Guam.
Do you know that they actually had trials over there?
War crime trials for Japanese soldiers and actually not soldiers.
The A,
the higher ups,
just like Nuremberg and people got put to death and hung,
you know,
not a lot of them,
but they still did.
And there was all kinds of fucking atrocities that happened over there.
I had no idea.
I think basically for the most part,
you can Google any country anywhere and just type in war crimes after it.
Okay.
You know,
that's what blows my mind about all of that shake.
And they've said it before,
like what we did in Dresden and all that.
If we lost like the,
when we fire bomb that city,
they were just like,
yeah,
you realize if we lose that,
we're going to be sitting there waiting to get honk.
You realize this shit.
And then they just go,
you know what?
It's like a roulette wheel and they just push all their chips on red,
fucking spin the wheel and drop the marble.
You know,
how do you sleep at night running a fucking war.
Okay.
You know,
just knowing that if you lose,
you're going to be sitting there with your head down,
you know,
with your fucking headphones on,
listening to people,
talking about what a monster you are.
Okay.
The same people who did basically what the fuck you did.
Okay?
To a certain extent,
except now they're,
they're considered heroes.
And then you'll get that.
It's the fucking worst,
you know?
And then those guys write a letter of thank you for being such a class act or
your fucking during your trial.
So anyways,
day you'd go.
So now you know people,
one capital I taught you this week,
cat man,
dude,
there was some reason it's spelled k a t h m a n d o Kathmandu.
Swap going to cat man.
Um,
let's give to the letters for this week,
everybody and it starting off.
Speaking of war crimes,
speaking of death,
speaking of things,
um,
what do we got here?
Cadaver lab.
Okay.
It's a good name for a band that isn't that good.
You know,
meet some chick.
You want to fuck her and she can't because she's dating the lead singer of
cadaver lab.
And you're just sitting in your head like going cadaver lab,
like,
okay,
that's the name of the band.
Let me guess.
Do they have a bunch of props on stage of people bleeding?
Did an Alice Cooper already do that 40 fucking years ago?
Can you just spread your legs and get some normal dick in you,
sweetheart?
You know?
Okay.
Local heroes,
cadaver lab signed to Electra elect records,
a dear billion.
I work at a medical device company and southern Massachusetts and I know you
will be in the area for your shows.
All that's great.
You've just crossed promoted by shows.
That's like a Jimmy Norton.
Bit from way back in the day on Opie and Anthony Show on the opie and Anthony
Show,
the opie and Anthony Program,
if you want to get official,
he goes,
I see you're going to be in the area doing some shows and want to see if you're
interested in coming into a cadaver lab.
Knees,
shoulders only.
No faces or bodies.
Well,
what the fuck,
dude?
That's just just like watching a movie trailer,
but you don't get to see the movie.
He said,
I designed a screw to repair slash rebuild your ACL.
I know you and Joe Rogan talked about it.
I taught,
I didn't talk about it.
That's definitely some Rogan's stuff right there.
Uh,
I'm too dumb to talk about shit like that.
This podcast is the exact,
it's opposite of the Joe Rogan experience where Joe actually facts checks like
shit.
Did I say my fact checks?
Shit.
I can't even get through this sentence.
I don't,
I just sort of,
you know,
overhear things and then I just presented as fact.
So anyways,
I know you and Joe Rogan talked about it,
but if you would like to see a jackass like me,
try to repair one in a lab,
please let me know.
You don't have to touch anything
or you can,
if you want,
let me know.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
You know what,
dude?
I think you've been working in a cadaver lab too long that you feel that you can
just openly invite me to this.
Okay.
I don't have to touch anything,
but I can if I want.
Like I just want to fucking squeeze somebody's dead knee.
That's not attached to anything.
Why in God's name would I want that on my hard drive?
Why would I want to know what that feels like?
Okay.
To squeeze a rigor.
Mortor I fucking neek
sir.
Are you like a serial killer?
And you're looking for a partner,
you know,
like that fucking classic one that I watch where they,
one of the greatest lines ever uttered on television when they were talking
about when the first serial killer met the second serial killer,
cause he went to a new town,
said move to some new town there.
He made it.
He made a pyromaniac and sometimes transvestite or a transvestite and sometimes
pyromaniac.
That's how they described this guy.
He was a cross dressed and sometimes pyromaniac.
Um,
and then they hooked up and they did a bunch of murders together.
you know,
I,
I do find that fascinating and I know that your work is leading to a better good
for people who are alive.
But,
uh,
you know,
there's things in comedy that I know you wouldn't want to see.
So I would invite you backstage during particular fucking moments,
you know?
And that's what you're basically doing it
all right.
Now if you had the entire fucking body that that's another thing that's just,
it's just disrespectful for me to go down there.
Like I'm going to see world looking at body parts.
So that's what happens.
Like when fump is somebody a
okay,
like donates their body to science.
Yeah.
Like they just take your fucking,
yeah,
we'll just take the knee.
Like do you guys go to like the butcher?
Yeah,
let me get a pork shoulder and a somebody kneecap.
Okay.
Hey,
feel like working on acs,
man.
It gets a great thing that you do that.
Just that,
you know,
it's funny,
I have no problem getting cremated because even some fucked up reason,
you still feel it.
I mean it's gonna suck.
Yeah.
For like 45 minutes or a couple hours,
however long it takes to burn you down to ash,
you know,
and is awful.
And as horrific as that sounds,
being slowly burned for fucking two hours.
MMM.
It's over in two hours.
Whereas if you fucking lane in a box,
completely intact,
full of preservatives,
you just slowly decomposing over a hundred fucking years.
I don't want to do that.
Get it over with,
but that does freak me out that you're going to sit there and you know,
have my fucking knee on one table,
my shoulder on the other [inaudible]
you know,
so drew Brees can fucking throw a better pass and I was just fucking weird.
Um,
you know,
if that was really country,
you invited me and a I didn't accept and then I was a deck and I trashed what
the fuck you do obviously to come on dude.
You got to understand.
All right.
I'm,
yeah,
that's,
I can't do that.
I preach.
Thank you for the invitation.
They would just be weird.
I'd show up with DVDs.
There you go.
And appreciation that you've shown me this ankle.
Um,
married women.
Hey Bill,
I know what I'm doing is wrong.
Oh,
I'm a single guy who became friends with a married woman at work.
Here we go.
Devious maids.
We have a ton of stupid shit and common.
We even like the same flavor chips.
I know it's retarded.
Uh,
we became Facebook friends.
How did you become Facebook friends?
But just be honest with me.
You,
sorry.
You wanted to fuck her and you knew she was married and you didn't give a shit.
All right.
I've been there.
Um,
here we go.
We,
yeah,
we have like the same flavor chips.
We became Facebook friends and little by little her messages starting getting
sexual.
Yeah.
And I'm sure you didn't facilitate that on any,
you,
you weren't stoking those fucking flames or whatever the expression goes.
You weren't fucking blowing on the hot coals at all.
Right?
You were just sitting there talking about earth,
wind and fire and all of a sudden she's like,
speaking of fire,
my pussy is raging right now for your cock to be in it.
And you were like,
whoa.
Hey,
where did that come from?
I,
I was just talking old R and B music.
Um,
it's at the point where she comes right out and told me she wants to fuck me.
Okay.
She's smoking hot with no kids.
And it's so fucking hard not to do something.
It goes against all my beliefs,
but I can't stop thinking about it.
I have a feeling she wants out of her marriage,
but I don't want to be a homewrecker.
Uh,
I've also have to see her at work,
so it's extra hard to tell her.
Just tell her to fuck off.
I listened to you every Monday and usually tell guys to whack it and see if the
feeling goes away.
Well,
I already did that and it didn't work.
I'm just an average attractive guy and want to fuck her.
But like I said,
I know it's wrong.
Can you just come to Canada and shoot me in the fucking head?
That's hilarious.
Oh,
and he said from Scotland and also she's loving that accent.
Um,
all right,
dude,
not only are you going to be the fucking a married woman,
it's where you work and the odds of that coming out and once you start fucking
somebody at work,
as much as you try and keep it on the down low,
everybody knows they can tell by your body language.
Everybody at work already knows that you guys want to fuck each other.
They already know that.
So when you do fuck,
everybody's going to know that.
And then in six months when you go to get a raise and you walk in there and it's
either gonna be a,
you're sitting across the desk from some other guy that wanted to fuck her but
didn't in,
is jealous of you.
Or B,
it's a woman who's jealous of that hot pitch that you fucked and wants to be as
skinny as her and is actually annoyed on some subconscious level that you didn't
try to fuck her,
even though she wouldn't have fucked you either way.
It's going to affect your money.
Uh,
don't do it.
Don't do it.
Been there,
done that.
Trust me.
Don't fucking do it.
It does not end well.
All right?
You don't want that on your resume.
It's awful.
It's an unforgivable act.
Um,
don't do it.
All right?
You don't want to do it.
Your deck wants to do it.
And this is a great opportunity to beat the fucking steal from the Seinfeld
Shell to be master of your domain.
All right?
You don't have to tell her to fuck off.
Just say listen.
All right.
I would love to have sex with you too,
but I can't do it while you're still married.
So when that situation changes come by and knock on the nonexistent door of my
cubicle and I will put you right on my fucking generic plastic desks that
everybody else has that was fucking bulk ordered from some staple somewhere and
I'll fuck you in front of everybody.
I'll have my fucking aux face right over the top of it
cubicle
and I'll fuck you right here at work.
But until then,
get out of my career.
What movie was that?
Get Out of my crib.
Um,
all right,
wild bill.
I'm 28 and had been living in Japan for five years.
I was probably pretty cool.
What an experience,
uh,
for the past year and a half,
I've been dating a fine specimen of a woman from your country,
but recently ended things.
Well,
I'm glad you did.
Considering you,
you look at her like she's something you've collected in a lab.
Do this.
So many people who are so close to being in a fucking serial killer,
a fine specimen.
You sound like one of those Nazi fucking doctors once that's,
it's a very fine specimen.
It's a human being man.
Um,
a large part of this was due to us being from different countries,
her being from the Good Ole USA,
me being from another guy from Scotland,
these guys from Scotland are fucking killing it.
I wish I could do a good Scottish accent.
Okay.
I can't,
only thing I could,
the only thing I can kind of do in a Scottish accent is,
is the shit that they said to me.
What the fuck is the fucking podcast?
Um,
and that was probably terrible.
Right?
Oh my God,
that's more like northern Iln shut up.
Nobody cares.
Okay.
All right.
Where am I going here?
A large part of this was due to us being from different countries and her being
from the good old USA,
me being from Scotland and our employment contracts coming to an end in a few
weeks.
Originally,
she planned to come back with me,
but now I'll be braving Scotland alone.
Since the breakup I been,
I've been feeling down and generally acting like a little emo bitch,
crying,
drowning my sorrows and worrying that I'll never get with anyone ever again.
Let's stop right here,
sir.
There's no raw.
There's,
there's nothing wrong with feeling like that and addressing it and crying.
That's exactly what you supposed to do.
That's what the ladies though and that's why they're more,
they,
they don't die as soon as we do.
You can't push that shit down.
Cry Like literally to not cry ism you're denying a natural emotion.
It'd be like,
would you ever deny being happy?
I like,
you know,
I'm going to laugh.
I got to go to four.
Can tough it out and not left.
He got to let it out.
That's your body trying to heal itself.
If you don't,
that shit just stays in your,
it just spoons around your fucking arteries.
I'm telling you,
dude,
that was one of the greatest things I saw when Chris Bosch,
when they lost the fucking NBA championship and he walked down the tunnel,
it just collapsed and just fucking cried it out.
Do you understand how advanced of a human being that guy is a man that he could
do that and did it?
TV,
cameras,
whatever and just said,
yeah,
I was disappointed.
I just needed to cry it out of me and I feel better.
You know,
I think it's a great thing.
Oh,
by the way,
if,
yeah,
if you miss that.
I was on Conan this week.
Um,
the wonderful people over there.
I had me on the show again.
God,
she's somewhat of,
I'm an asshole.
Don't even thinking here.
Um,
the movie,
the heat,
everybody is the number one movie in the country.
From what I heard.
I didn't look it up,
but I heard it did really well.
So I want to thank everybody for going out to see it.
I want to thank Conan O'brien and everybody at the corner of Brian Show for
letting me come on the show.
Run my mouth.
And a hype,
the movie like to thank Paul Feig,
the director for putting me in the movie and everybody else that I got to work
with.
Um,
it's,
I,
I went to a screening of it last week.
It was fucking awesome.
Bunch of big laughs.
Please go see it.
Um,
cause it would help me out and everybody else in the movie would really help it
out.
So thank you to everybody who went to go see it.
Thank you to anybody even thought about seed it and a whatever.
Chris Bosch was,
um,
was one of the guests on a,
on the show and I was going to say hello to him,
but I always,
I always get like a little freaked out before I have to go do a panel.
You know,
it's like you gotta
I was trying to think like,
what the fuck am I going to talk about?
And I don't like going out there having like,
I dunno,
I like going out there and just saying something because then that sets me into
just be in there rather than,
you know,
like when you do that,
they do these things where they do like a pre interview,
they'll do it on radio and everything and then it just becomes this weird phony
conversation where you come walking out there and they just go,
you know,
hey bill,
have you ever,
uh,
let your foot on fire while Mowing Alon?
And then I go,
as a matter of fact,
I have,
I was of my lunch,
it's like,
it's almost like delta host is,
has like ESP,
you know what I mean?
And there's that whole,
just trying to fucking fake your way into doing this thing that everybody knows
you're going to do.
So,
uh,
I always try to fucking throw something out there and uh,
and Conan's awesome.
Cause he just fucking rolls with it and I always have a great time.
So,
um,
and always get more fans by doing that show.
So,
uh,
thanks again to everybody over there and Kona for getting me on it.
If you missed it,
I reteach.
I retweeted the,
uh,
the,
whatever,
whatever your kids call it,
the clip there.
And I'll be doing it again this week on the podcast page and you could watch my
little interview there.
You should actually watch the whole show.
It's a great shell.
Um,
anyways,
let's,
let's plow ahead here.
Uh,
where the fuck am I sensed the breakup of feeling down crime above however,
now that those feelings have subsided,
the real worry is not whether I'll find someone,
but what kind of person?
Yeah,
I'm talking about looks here.
Okay.
I currently live in an area of Japan.
Famed for its beauty through this guy is just crushing it.
This is what you do when you're a young man,
is you move to another country with beautiful.
Every country has beautiful women.
You just move there and all of a sudden you're fucking interesting.
Just cause you,
you're asking them where the restroom is just cause you have an accent right
there.
You're going to get 40% more pussy if even remotely have any game,
it's going to happen for you.
All right?
I currently live in an area of Japan,
famed for its beauties.
Scotland on the other hand does not boast this distinction and also has the
highest level of obesity in Europe.
Does it?
I didn't notice any fat people over there.
I mean,
I just think in general,
Great Britain,
just people have that fish and chips torso.
Then again,
I am coming from the states,
you know,
we go hard out here.
Um,
so what advice can you give to a poor wee laddie for returning to a country of
bad food?
Even worse weather and now also finding himself having to wade through a dating
pool of biological clock ticking,
tanning challenged third round draft pick ladies.
That's Hilarious,
dude.
You know what?
The only thing I can tell you save up your money and you gotta go back.
You got to go back.
Not only you got to go back to where they have even better looking women than
where you were in Japan.
You know,
maybe go down to the Caribbean or something like that.
This is what it is.
You opened Pandora's box,
no pun intended.
And you know,
the selections that are out there see people who never traveled,
they just end up fucking somebody in their hometown and then they get married,
you know,
and it's just like they ate the same food their entire fucking life.
They don't know any better.
They don't understand how long the buffet table is of ladies that are out there.
You know?
Like if I was a guy right now getting,
I am a guy.
All right,
but let's just say I wasn't a guy.
No.
If I was some dude getting divorced and I didn't know where to turn and I was a
little bit older and that type of thing,
like that is what I would do.
I would fucking,
I'd go to,
I get a personal trainer,
I would get an unbelievable fucking shape and I would get my ass down to the
fucking Caribbean and I would find myself some island girl.
Absolute stunning beauty who's on island time is completely laid back and that
type of shit.
Right.
And uh,
I would fucking marry her.
I'd find love down there.
Start all over again.
It just fuck it.
You know,
it just given to their vibe.
Start walking around barefoot,
start chilling out.
Just relax it,
going out,
doing your fucking job,
making the money and then fucking common home did this absolute exotic beauty.
That's what the fuck I would do rather than they'd come home and go,
fuck the female version of you.
Yeah.
You know,
that's what I learned through travel.
So there you go,
sir.
That's what I would do.
I will get a job there and I would tough it out,
save up some fucking money and I would,
I would just literally Google where the most beautiful women are in the world.
Look at the pictures,
make the judgment for yourself and didn't just fucking move there.
You're young,
you don't have,
you're not tied down what?
He can always go back to Scotland,
you know,
but you could have some fucking beautiful lady on your arm.
It can happen.
All right,
but you got to take that first step,
sir.
You got to put your freckled foot down and just make that decision that you know
you're,
you're going to bet on yourself.
Give yourself a better life.
All right?
God bless you.
Good luck to you,
sir.
All right,
girlfriend hits me.
Jesus Christ.
How do you know soul having motherfucker?
Uh,
can we stop with the Hacky,
redheaded jokes?
You know what I mean?
Do you know how many times I've fucking heard that?
That we don't have any salt?
I don't have any soul.
Did you hear that sir?
Did you hear the wonderful advice that just came from my heart?
How could you say that?
You know what?
Just for that,
I'm not giving you any good advice.
I'm going to give you some terrible,
terrible advice here.
I'm 26 and I've been dating the same girl for almost a year.
She's a dime fucks like a champ.
Great job and family,
sweetest corn syrups and the whole fucking nine yards.
Anyways,
about three months ago into the relationship,
that's what he called it.
Everybody at the relationship.
You see what he did there?
He took the p out and put a t.
What's the deal with relationships?
He goes,
we get drunk at her friend's house and she starts going fucking nuts running
around.
I tried to talk to her and she slaps me right across the face.
I was seeing red,
bad enough self control to let it slide.
And the past two weeks,
however she is slapped me in front of my friends and squeeze my nuts to the
point of vomiting
cause I was playing
around and pissed her off.
Yeah.
Wow.
She squeezed you and not so hard.
You puked.
Were you drinking?
Okay.
He goes,
this is completely turned me off and it had made me seriously considered dumping
this broad too.
She grabbed your balls in,
squeeze to the point that you puked and you're still writing.
Make for advice.
How fucking hot is this girl?
Okay.
He goes,
I'm a big guy and obviously can't respond.
So I got to stand there like a Dildo and just take this shit.
Oh Dude.
At what size do you feel like you could come back with an overhand right?
Uh,
although I got to tell you that there really is nothing funnier though.
If a guy's slaps her,
fuck it.
He's seen that video on the,
on the Internet with that woman's slap said security guard and he fucking slaps
her right back and she is stunned for like a second and a half and then just
puts her hands up like a little kid just goes,
uh,
I am not pro violence towards women.
I am not,
but that is some funny shit and I stand by it.
Go Fuck Yourself.
It's fucking hilarious.
All right.
She got the old right there Fred.
Um,
yeah.
Oh right there Fred.
For New People,
I've told you what that expression means,
but before I do that,
I really need to fucking,
you guys are using cold lotion incorrectly.
You'll be like Chicago Blackhawks speed the Bruins and six games.
That's some cold lotion.
That's not cold lotion.
Alright.
Cold Lotion is when somebody goes to do something nice for you and then they,
it's this like something bad about it.
Like Nia said,
can you put some lotion on my back?
That's a beautiful,
loving,
nice thing to do.
But I didn't warm it up in my hands and I just put it on her back and it was
cold lotion to get it.
So I still put lotion on her back.
Her skin wasn't dry.
I did a re solid,
but the way I did it cost like this fucking jolt,
this uncomfortableness.
That is the definition.
It's actually the definition of is up on what the urban dictionary or whatever
it is up there.
All right,
so the Blackhawks speeding the Bruins and six games is not cold lotion because
that,
that would be like,
they would have let us win on some level,
but also fucking,
uh,
blew out one of our guys knees.
But they did let us win.
That would be,
I guess,
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
let's get back to this shit,
shall we?
So anyways,
to refresh your memory before I went off on that tangent.
All right.
She's slapping him in front of friends and squeezes nuts to the point of
vomiting and evidently,
um,
you know,
they're not in the same weight class,
so he can't hit her back.
He goes,
I'm just afraid someday in the future I'll go into rage mode and end up crushing
your head on the stove or something and ruin my life.
Yeah,
dude,
you have to get out of this.
And he goes,
I might go into rage.
Moe's end up crushing your head on the stove or something and ruined my life.
Anyways,
love you.
And looking forward to hearing you read this in your own clown voice.
Um,
all right,
well sir,
uh,
you have to break up with this woman.
It's not even a question dude.
She quit.
She squeezed your balls to the point of view puking.
It's fucking over.
It's over.
All right.
You need the dumper.
And the problem is,
is you know what probably nobody has ever dumped her and that's why she's so
fucking out of line.
So why don't you do it?
You know,
you kind of fucked up now cause you didn't do it
in the moment.
You should have done it the next day and just been like,
do you realize how fucking hot align,
they don't even know.
Don't curse.
You just stay really calm and just say,
listen,
Nah,
okay.
Um,
I don't want to see you anymore.
I just don't,
I just,
you know,
uh,
I don't know how to fucking do it.
I,
I can't do it without Carson.
You know,
you're fucking psycho and a,
you squeezed my balls until I puked.
And um,
you haven't even apologized.
You like that much of a dumb cunt.
And
no matter how smart I am,
my kids are going to be cut with your half a dump.
Qantas.
So,
you know,
and whenever I see them do something dumb,
I go,
I'm going to know that it's you and that I shouldn't have dumped a load new.
So I,
yeah,
I,
I just can't see it anymore
duty.
Are you going when you break up with you,
it can be wearing one of those dog,
you know,
let those suits you wear when you're training a dog.
How to attack people.
Little beekeeper hat and a cup.
No,
sir.
If,
if you're actually,
you know,
having fantasies of slamming her head on a stove top.
Yeah,
I would definitely get out of it before you ruin your life.
Um,
yeah.
Unreal,
ashy and you don't do,
you don't want to do that.
After watching the unbelievably depressing and sad story of Aaron Hernandez,
you know,
just watching somebody losing their life and then somebody else just throwing
their life away and that fucking depression depression where you're just like,
you know,
is everybody's out there chasing money.
You just feel like,
you know,
if I had all that money and I had a big house,
I would finally be happy and my life would be perfect.
And just seeing somebody have all of that and,
and just throwing it all away,
it was one of the most depressing fucking things I've ever seen in my life.
Um,
creepy chilling,
the whole,
the whole fucking nine yards,
you know?
And this is how fucking hilarious Boston fans are.
My friends are calling me up going,
you bleed this Hernandez story.
Go,
yeah.
Oh my God,
I can't believe.
And they just go,
yeah,
you know,
what the fuck,
now what do we do?
Gronk so always getting hurt.
Who's Brady going to throw to if he fucking,
it's like,
you know,
I think there's something a little bigger than trying to beat the dolphins have
the jets this year.
I think the fact that,
uh,
okay,
you know that people died and it just,
it's unbelievable.
I'm fucking believe that like,
if,
if what they're saying is true,
this guy literally like killed two people in the next week.
He's on sports center,
you know,
talking to some,
report it and then some lady,
they always have,
they always have the ladies down on the sidelines,
you know,
and he's sitting there smiling and waving and then his head,
he's like,
yeah,
I just killed two people.
Um,
creepy.
Anyways,
odd question.
Hey Bill.
Hey Billy.
I've been enjoying your podcast and stand up for a while and have some odd
issues.
I'm a 17 year old guy and haven't really been social or outgoing most of my
life.
Well did you're only 17.
I W I was walled off too.
Um,
but recently I've had about three girls start making advances towards me and not
really sure how to manage that.
Uh,
go with the dude.
Just go with it.
Just take them out to you.
Let's sweat.
You have to do,
you have to push through your first fucking date.
All right.
And the longer you go,
the more fucking more of a mountain.
It's going to seem like it really isn't.
Dude.
You're stepping over a rake.
That's all it is.
You know,
it's fucking,
it's,
it's an eighth of an inch off the ground.
Just go out there.
Everybody makes an ass of themselves when they first start fucking courting a
lady,
just take them out.
Go to a fucking movie,
Go see the heat.
I heard it's a wonderful movie.
Um,
anyways,
he says,
and not really sure how to manage that,
but now the more issues,
the one girl in particular who I really like has been getting pretty physical.
We had some pretty close moments that,
a couple of sleepovers and during the last one she started taking off my belt.
I gently moved her hands away and brought them up to my chest level,
but she's been more sexually aggressive in terms of initiating stuff than me.
Why am I you ask,
you'd be probably,
where did you get molested?
I'm going to guess.
He goes,
why am I you ass?
Don't I want to give up it up to this girl?
He goes,
well,
I have a small Dick.
Oh Man.
He goes,
laugh it up,
whatever.
Go.
Fuck Dude.
I would never laugh at you like that.
Having a big Dick of a small dick is not a skill.
It's just luck of the draw.
Okay.
He goes,
I make up for it in character.
So not asking for a from experience cause you sound,
because from the sound of it,
you're doing just fine,
dude.
I'm average.
I'm fucking right down the middle.
You know,
my Dick was a car.
It would be a fucking tourists.
No,
that's a full sized car.
What am I saying?
It would just be like,
you know,
an ultima.
Yes.
You know,
it's not going to scare you.
It's not going to disappoint you.
You know,
it's a friend.
Um,
all right,
well it's dependable.
What am I going here?
Uh,
do you have any advice what to do?
I really want to be with this girl,
but I feel like she may lose interest in me or write me off because of it and
I'm destined to die a virgin.
I got to know what to do and I can't ask my friends for obvious reasons.
Any response would mean the world to me.
Thanks for making the world a little brighter by the way.
You make people smile,
Bill.
And that's pretty important.
Some fans,
some fan with the development issue.
Um,
though this is a uh,
okay,
this is,
this is
okay
beyond my capabilities other than to say like,
I would really talk to somebody,
you know what I mean?
Because this is really like a crucial fucking thing where yeah,
you could be so embarrassed or something like that that it's going to cause you
to miss out on being with somebody.
Look,
there's guys with little dig said get married all the fucking time who find love
and that type of thing.
So your situation is not hopeless.
You know,
there's guys with fucking big bleed it,
there's women with big Dick Women big that this women with it,
with guys with beer,
there's women out there with big dicks toe.
You know,
there's just a whole bunch of fucking people out there.
Everybody.
And I don't judge any of them.
There's women out there with guys who have fucking big dicks that,
uh,
you know,
they're out there fucking around on them or they don't have a fucking job.
You know,
there's,
it's not all roses.
All right.
And after awhile,
I swear to God,
after awhile all the fuck a woman wants you to do is just bring home some God
damn money.
Just have a fucking job.
Treat me with respect and raise our kids.
Right?
If you do that,
you're hitting a fucking home run.
All right?
So,
um,
I would seek out some professional advice and then,
I dunno,
dude,
I,
you know what I,
if I had a fucking little Dick,
I would just own it.
Okay.
I don't,
it,
it just get it out there.
Just fucking tell her right off the bat,
you know,
and then I would fucking please her at least two,
three times before I fucking went to go do my business.
And uh,
okay.
Yeah.
I this,
I think that's just something,
you just got to get it out there.
I,
that's
what I would guess,
but I would definitely talk to somebody about it because this is obviously,
I mean,
obviously it's bothering you.
Would fucking bother anybody and I want you to succeed,
you know?
So that's what I would do.
Does that make sense?
I hope that fucking helped you out.
The fuck did I do with my goddamn questions here?
It was still am the worst.
Um,
Jesus not going to look this.
Yeah,
seriously,
dude.
I,
I wouldn't,
I would never make fun of somebody for something like that.
You know what I mean?
I pick on people for,
for,
for writing.
Thank you.
Letters after winning a championship under the guise that they're actually
trying to do to us a fucking favor.
Jeez.
Jesus.
She'll swell.
Um,
all right,
let's get back to this here.
So good luck with that,
sir.
And,
um,
where the hell am I?
Odd Question.
Yeah.
All right.
I did that.
So that they go there.
There's,
there's the advice.
I hope that that was a positive thing for you.
All right.
Cause that's what I'm trying to say.
I would that I would never make fun of somebody for like something like that.
All right.
I think that's the end of the podcast people.
Um,
what do I got coming up?
Actually,
you know what,
I'm not on the road for a minute.
I got some big shows back east.
If you'd like to know about him,
he can go to bill bird.com.
Um,
I'm going to be at the Cape Cod melody tent and a,
I can't even tell you how thrilled I am to be doing that place.
Like I told you,
that's the place where the one and only time I ever saw George Carlin.
Uh,
so that's going to be an unbelievably special night for me.
So it will be a great show obviously.
And then,
uh,
um,
at the Hampton Beach Ball Room Casino,
this is all the weekend of July 12th.
And then I got,
uh,
the Newport yachting center.
So like I said,
that weekend I'm playing two tents and an addict.
All right?
That's the weekend of July 12th,
13th,
14th or 11th,
12th and 13th.
I don't have it in front of me,
but,
um,
tickets are going fast.
So thank you to everybody's who's been going out to my shows and that type of
stuff and blah,
blah,
blah.
And uh,
and with that,
we got to do the outros here.
Once again,
people,
if you forgot already,
um,
now that the show's over,
don't forget to sign up for your free trial of Hulu plus and start watching your
favorite hit TV shows right now.
Watch TV the way you want to,
wherever the hell you want to do it.
Just go to the podcast page at [inaudible] Dot Com and click on the Hulu plus
banner for your extended extended free trial or go to Hulu plus.com/bill and
also don't forget,
um,
if you starting your own business to set up your free trial of ee voice,
join the thousands of vulnerable entrepreneurs who've used he voice as their
personal receptionist,
24,
seven get your own toll free or local number.
Professional greetings have calls routed and all your voicemails transcribed and
emailed to you for less than 10 bucks month.
That's really
priceless.
Everybody right now.
You can try a voice for free for 30 days.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com Promo code bill,
um,
or click on the voice banner at the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com alright,
and with that,
I'm trying to get into a baseball everybody.
I'm slowly getting back into it and wanting to start watching the Dodgers.
I actually watched the red sox beat the Blue Jays at,
believe it was yesterday on the final play.
The game,
somebody hit a little flair.
I'm going to get back into it.
I'll get back into it.
If the fucking Black Hawks would stop sending fucking thank you letters
reminding me of what I already know,
you know,
picking that fucking scab.
Um,
yeah,
that's it.
I've decided I'm going to win brace baseball.
You know,
I got a nice little time off here.
I'm going to lose some weight,
you know,
take my dog on a short hike and then I'm going to go on the longer one,
like what I did today and I'm getting up myself in great fucking shape here for
the summer and I'm going to watch some baseball.
I'm actually gonna try to go back east.
Uh,
well,
I'm going to go back.
He said I'm would try to take it maybe a red sox game when I'm back there.
I haven't gone to a game and a couple of years,
but,
uh,
that's what I'm up to.
All right.
And that right there was the lackluster ending to this hopefully wonderful
podcast.
Once again,
thanks to Paul Feig and everyone who worked on the heat,
forget me in that.
Uh,
please go see it this week.
If you haven't seen it already,
go see it again or whatever.
Uh,
it'd be helping me out.
And,
uh,
and thanks to Conan O'brien and everybody on the Conan O'brien show,
let me come on and,
uh,
run my mouth and hype that project.
All right.
That's it.
That's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll talk to you next week.